so hi there hello and Who am I speaking
to today
my name is Santosh the fan Christ critic
Islam one of the things we're doing is
we come to speaker's corner pick after
week mainly to engage with Islamic Dawa
team defined by defending Christ also
critical ideology of Islam and today
what will you be speaking about today we
talked about the stunning verses of the
adulteress in Muslim countries it is
something practiced yet something
happened in seventh country a ship came
and that eight verse today it is not in
the crown we were challenging the
eternal word of Allah is not as a
complete book also we are talking about
the Hajj why people go to Hajj
approximate 2 million people are in Hajj
for 10 days and one of the practices
that practice they will be doing is
kissing the black stone it is in a sense
committing shirk yet 2 million people
are following that because Mohammed
peace is something so we are questioning
the shift in Islam and also we are
questioning why to kiss the black stone
in Mecca okay you're one of the more
famous people of pastilles corner you're
famous for your m33 versions of the
quran yeah have you ever experienced
violence's I wouldn't say I am famous
but I am regular it's because collar I'm
here week after week yes one of the
research I have done was to look at the
claim that Quran is all over the world
is
on there I put together 32 different
Arabic runs with thousands of textual
variations as you can understand that
didn't go very well yes there are there
were the times that we were we were we
had harassments we word we get death
threats or we get violence has been
practice buttons it does happen so you
knew the Battle of Yamamah the Battle of
Yamamah
it was when most of the caranas were
killed yeah all those people who had
recited the Quran to memory they're all
killed
so how can you have a Quran when no one
remembers that in theirs Muslim
compilations so Islamic tradition tells
us around 600 632 to 600 when people
learned about love your mama who
memorized the Quran they time it wasn't
thousands of people it was only fear of
people who died and suddenly Islamic
world become a bit conscious because
they cannot put two verses into the
crowd who memorized a title and people
died they took the Quran to themselves
that's where it's kind of all idea comes
from it shows us memorization of the
Quran is not perfect it shows us we
cannot trust the memorization and it
shows us that Quran is not perfectly
preserved because umar tells us that no
one can tell us we've got the whole
crown vial we've got only what survived
and a first coat the combination of the
quran which takes place around 634 it is
one of the action called Buddha which
innovation that Muhammad didn't do it
but Muslims practice it so it shouldn't
be practiced by Muslims and Muhammad
didn't work that much Buddha and war by
the die of critical markings it's
when you look at that one of the
earliest grunts you can see that they
have no dogs so all the Continental
letters without dog yet in Arabic
alphabet I'll show you some pictures
you cannot recognize the letters if you
don't have the dogs let me just show you
the picture if I can find it
I've got three questions to put here
this is the Koran at the time of
Muhammad this is one of the earliest one
you can see it has some dots okay and um
you can see there are some insertions
into the one of the earliest many
secrets okay I'm gonna show you more
examples
sorry that's gonna be taking time can I
just ask you something yeah okay so
Muslims I think wasn't the Quran written
in classical Arabic yeah I'm gonna show
you an example
hi so one of the earliest crowns again
all these Muslims in speakers corner
they all say you know the Quran can't be
translated so another one of the early
smelly secrets if you look at it you
will see it has more dogs it has no dots
without notes you cannot you are not
able to read all the Continental letters
for six of the six of them it's all
right but rest of it 20 of them
you need a dog five and five buck is the
letter well as they fill stops and
commas isn't it you know in Arabic
alphabet Arabic letter note and yeah
haha they're similar but they just need
talk to identify which consonantal
letter
I've got like posh girls they just
changed it sound and then make the world
solid so that's different place so M
Muslims always tell us that we can know
that the Quran cannot be translated
though we can never understand the Quran
yeah so we can never understand the
Quran why are all these English born
English speaking Muslims Muslims if they
can understand the Quran if it can't be
translated we come to the understand one
of the reason is first of all even Allah
says in the Quran Quran is well
explained well detailed and for whole
mankind if I cannot understand the
Kramden language I speak then I am
afraid I know two languages I'm Turkish
I can speak English and Turkish yet
Allah is not able to communicate with me
how can these Imams community - if I
wanted to convert to Islam as an
english-speaking person how could an
imam possibly communicate the Quran see
me since is so untranslatable first of
all if you want to convert to Islam
please don't do that
what you decided to give up Islam you
have to give up your I'm a
Christian don't convert Islam it is very
dangerous ideology but if you convert
the Islam one of the thing always asking
you to do it you need to stay
Creed in Arabic with the language you
don't understand and 85% of the Muslim
world cannot read and understand the
Arabic it is all about you memorize it
and you decided to eat well and that is
not very helpful do you think you think
about your eternity do you think
Mohammad actually split the moon into
lots of miracles one of the good thing
he did was feeding the cat
sadly no he didn't simply I mean they're
just it is in the Quran there is not of
in-house Thwaites but according to
hadith when he split them all once I
advantage is other side man to waste
vest vest but there is nothing anyone
tells us because we didn't have them all
fully we had the water come high but we
don't have anything what is their
gravity has that been affected by it in
some ha one point 84 billion missing
things mother maybe even economic the
altered shift that the ties the impact
of the moon splitting alone would
devastate the earth yeah I suppose a
Muslim class and she said to me well
Allah can control her
oh if Allah can control that Mohammed
the bitumen and unlock and control the
gravity don't you think that Allah
should be capable to communicate with
Malik on his world the language people
can understand and even the protect his
word from the ship Allah should do that
but he didn't do that
thank you so much first time was amazing
to meet you that's why I think so